my thing was that I just love doing
software I loved hiring people you
making money is selfish you making money
is short-term to me money stop being the
goal at $100,000 rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
its Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee unzip on today's message don't
make money your goal over to you Bill
Gates also if you want to know what Bill
Gates and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I believe in the
internet I believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that you are here with your daughter
who is 21 right and you were 21 when you
became a billionaire is that right
almost yeah all right so I round that
age you weren't you were like the
youngest person to become a billionaire
is that right yeah yeah in terms of my
own earning it on my own yeah right okay
so what's the most important thing yeah
so did you when you were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's it
just happened mostly I loved software I
do remember at the private school I went
to there were other kids whose families
were better off like they had a porch or
something but it wasn't that that big of
a deal my thing was that I just love
doing software I loved hiring people and
I was stunned when it ended up being so
valuable really yeah you it surprised
you yeah because I always had to be
careful that we wouldn't hire too many
people I was always worried because I've
people who work for me were older than
me and they had kids and I always
thought well what if we don't get paid
will I be able to meet the payroll
so I was always very conservative about
the finances and then when we did go
public
what was I thirty by then then I was
kind of stunned at what it multiplied
out to you can't make making money your
number one goal if making money is your
number one goal if you are so desperate
to make money what it does is force you
into stupid short-sighted short-term
decisions that actually prevent you from
building a real business and making real
money the process of making short-term
money is often against the very process
of actually making real money the
decisions that you make to make
short-term cash prevent you from
building a real business and making real
money so let's look at my youtube
channel as an example if I was desperate
for money if I needed to make money in
the next week I had some huge bill to
pay and I needed to make money I could
make that happen
I could make every video for the next
week super promotional we do three
videos a day I could do twenty-one
videos that are all hyper promotional
pumping you out to different products
and services that I make some money from
doing it and it would work I could
generate some real money in the next
week but most of you would then leave
most of you would unsubscribe from my
channel the short-term action to
generate cash because I'm desperate for
it goes against me actually building a
real business and generating real wealth
it's great to be hungry it's great to
have Drive it's great to have goals and
ambition but it's not great to be
desperate when you are desperate you do
stupid things when you are desperate you
force yourself into a short-term game
when you are desperate you do the things
that are against the very thing that you
want to go off and build don't be
desperate be hungry and if you want to
make money is about providing value
that's the number one rule of money if
you want people to pay you you have to
give them value the more value you bring
the more they're gonna pay you that's
one of the most important things and so
what you want to think about is how do I
become a value generating machine
and by creating immense value whether
it's for the masses like I'm doing or
for individual customers in your
business how can you be an immense value
generating machine and if you do that if
that's your focus if that's your number
one priority create as much value as
possible for your customers you will
make more money you will make more money
than you ever imagined money is
important it's just not number one by
changing your mindset on being a value
getting the Machine what it does is make
the focus on the customer your audience
and not you you making money is selfish
you making money is short-term the
customer getting value the customer
growing their business the customer
accomplishing their goals and getting
the problems that they have solved by
you is the game that you want to play is
how you ultimately get paid okay so
that's some great theory now how do you
actually go out and provide the value
I'm gonna give you three ways to do it
so you can start getting paid to number
one become a chief goal officer the CEO
that is your hat wear that every day not
just when you're talking to customers
but also your suppliers your employees
everybody around you you want to know
what their goal is what is their outcome
not just a product or service you're
providing but what is their goal I like
to say the most dangerous thing you tell
me is your goal if you are in my inner
circle and I'm hanging around you the
most dangerous thing that you can tell
me is your goal
I am a goal reverse engineer I am a
chief goal officer I want to understand
the goals of all the people around me
because then I want to go out and help
make that happen even if they won't do
it for themselves
your immediate priority for all your
customers is to be the chief goal
officer understanding what their goals
are and then figure out how you can help
them even if it has nothing to do with
the business that you are providing I'll
give you two quick examples one is a
client of mine Sage have been working
them for the past three years I was
speaking at one of their events it hired
me to come in and speak great they want
me to come and speak at the event I know
what the audience is I know what the
topic isn't supposed to talk about most
speakers come in they speak they leave I
asked the person who hired me
what are your metrics what is
goals how you measuring success here and
his response was we need to get X
million of impressions on Twitter that
was the number one goal coming out of
that event we need X million impressions
on Twitter how are you measuring it well
it's the number of tweets times that
person's followers at the time I had
about a hundred thousand people on
following me on Twitter so if I got one
tweet out mention the hash tag that'd be
a hundred thousand impressions they
wanted I forget what the number was X
number of million like great I'm gonna
do that myself I went back to my hotel
and I scheduled a couple hundred posts
that night so that just myself just
myself I would accomplish that metric
for them on top of live tweeting on top
of replying to people and putting the
hash tag in just me just me alone I'm
gonna help blow past that target it was
not why I was hired it was not the
speech that they wanted me to give but
it was their most important metric and
so this guy who was working at the
company could then go show his boss said
look we hit our metric he's the hero and
I help making a hero only because I was
a chief goal officer and that helped
lead to a three-year deal it wasn't if I
do this for you then you come and give
me this it was this is your goal I'm
gonna help you I will will this into
existence I'm gonna give you tons of
leverage I'm gonna make you look great
in your company and if at the end of the
day to give you nothing back okay but if
you keep doing that over and over and
over again you will get rewarded and my
reward was a three-year deal my second
example is with beau Hawkins beau has a
YouTube channel called four-minute
masters he didn't interview with wim HOF
I was trying to get in touch with wim
HOF he was a fan of the channel I forget
how he initially connected he introduced
me to him Hoff I ended up coming to his
event in Toronto we made a great video
on it it's on my channel had a fantastic
experience with with my wife Nina I got
to know beau and as a result he was
really trying to get to garyvee he
wanted garyvee on his channel now I know
Gary we've collaborated a bunch of times
lots of people want in shows - Gary I
never give in chose - Gary because I
respect his time and I know that he
doesn't want to be promoted and pitched
too
constantly but Bo gave me so much value
bo helped me out so much was a supporter
was a champion was giving me
introductions and I thought it'd be a
good fit for what Gary was doing and so
I made the introduction to Gary I think
he's the only guy who I made an
introduction to Gary and he did a quick
interview with Gary and put it up on his
channel fast forward to today Bo now has
a show on my channel it's the Bo show
he's done interviews with Lisa Nichols
and Mel Robbins and a bunch of other
people that we've got lined up and I'm
giving him even more opportunities on my
channel because I love how much value he
has brought to me he was a chief goal
officer for me it's the flip side he was
a chief goal officer for me he
understood what I wanted and he helped
give it to me and now I'm fighting to
give him more opportunities I'm fighting
to help him win because I want to see
this guy blow up now bo could have made
the introduction to win for me and I say
thank you and I never do anything I
could have been a total ass
I could never help him he asked to be
intro to Gary and say no or I ignore him
I could never talk to him ever again in
my life that will happen not everybody
will reciprocate but if you do it
consistently for the rest of your life
for everybody that you meet if you are
focused on not just a product or service
that you are selling but being the chief
goal officer understand what their most
important metric is understanding what
makes them tick and what their goals are
and then helping them accomplish it even
if it has nothing to do with the product
or service that you are offering it
needs to be part of every single client
that you work with especially if you're
in the service business you're dealing
with a few large clients every one of
them you need to understand what their
goals are reverse engineer and then go
out of your way I would challenge you
all to find one thing that you can do
for your clients that have nothing to do
with the part of the service that you
offer that helps them move closer on
their goals you help them accomplish
their goals make them look good to their
boss or get the targets that they're
after and you will win I guarantee it be
the chief goal officer number two is bet
the dog there's a an old expression in
leadership that says you should always
go to funerals but the weddings are
optional
writings are optional funerals are
mandatory celebrating with somebody is
great but going to the funeral being
there when they need help is where you
need to be like vet the doc bet the dog
that you don't think is a dog you put
your money on the dog the one that
everybody else is Pam donor right now
the one that everybody else is saying
you suck your company sucks
you're the worst human being alive right
people I just slamming them they've had
loss at their loss but you see something
you know they're gonna rebound you you
know they're gonna take off and you are
the one who supports them that the dog
don't be there when they're winning
don't be like all their other fake
friends and only show up to the
celebrations bet the dog pay close
attention to when your clients are
losing pay close attention to when your
partner's your suppliers your employees
the people around you are losing and be
the only person who believes in them
when nobody else does bet the dog so
quick example I look at Tony Robbins
Tony Robbins we've done a lot of work
with his team we've done a lot of videos
we've done a lot of exposure they've
given gifts of live seminars to my
audience it's been a great working
relationship when I want to continue and
I personally have learned a lot from
Tony Robbins he not so long ago got
caught up in the meat to controversy not
for him having been in sexual abuse
relationship or anything but just his
stance on it or his opinion of trying to
help a woman in in the conference that
he was at and he took some heat for it
and the media was with slamming Tony
Robbins for a week and a half as soon as
it happened as soon as it happened I
emailed his team and said guys I see
this happening I want to support is
there anything I can do and it led to a
couple articles and tweeting it out and
showing some support bent the dog and
Tony Robbins is not a dog but in that
moment he was being dogged and so I
wanted to be the person that his team
knows has his back another quick example
sage a client that I work with got
downgraded in the stock market by a big
analyst to sell that's like that's a
huge kiss of death that really sucks if
you're the CEO and you're your stock
gets downgraded to sell
that sucks in immediate reaction email
guys can I help can we do a video can I
be part of the the PR campaign to help
it go positive can we talk about the
future can we talk about helping
entrepreneurs like what can I do to help
where if they're hitting record earnings
and they're growing the stock prices to
the Ruth everybody thinks are great and
I might send a message to say
congratulations but that gets lost
amongst all the other messages of
congratulations right bet the dog when
they are down saij is not a dog but they
might be getting dogged everybody gets
dogged at some point everybody nobody
wins all the time 100%
everybody gets dog be the only person
who supports them when they are being
dogged it's also part of the reason why
I love being the first guest some people
shows when people write to me and
they're launching a podcast or YouTube
channel or Instagram Live or whatever it
is and they want me to come on
I love being guest number one I love it
I find it so much fun because right now
they're the dog right you're the dog
you're the underdog nobody believes in
you most people would say no I'm winning
a show people want to look at your your
data and your analytics and how many
people are following you and how many
downloads do you get I care easy I don't
even look at that stuff I care about you
I want to see your passion your fire
energy you're doing this for the right
reasons we have a decent connection like
that's what I want to see in the email
in the message in the DM that's what I'm
paying attention to not how big your
audience sizes because most people who
are at the level that I'm at if you look
at followers or entrepreneurship or
whatever
most people they care deeply about if
I'm gonna spend time with you I want to
make sure that it's invested wisely I
want to make sure that you're getting
lots of downloads and lots of views on
this thing right you're a doc and I love
it right I love betting on the underdog
always and forever I still resonate way
more with the startup entrepreneurs then
then with the people who have millions
of dollars and fancy cars and fancy
condos and apartments and homes now most
of these shows don't take off most
people who launched a podcast they quit
a lot of times people quit after one
episode I might be their first guess and
then they quit and they're out it's fine
not everybody's gonna win in fact most
people won't but the ones who do the
ones who win I'm proud that I was the
first guest early as part of that
progress and the ones who don't I'm
still proud that I tried to help and
they remember it they remember it for
all the people who said no for other
people they reached out to who ignored
them who said no I'm the one who said
yes I bet the dog and that gets
remembered and so look at your clients
pay attention your customers your
employees your partner's your
relationships the people who are around
you when they are at allö when people
are nagging on them when they had a loss
after loss after loss when they are the
dog and nobody wants to touch them you
go and give them the handout you will be
remembered forever
that's provide an insane value bette the
dog tip number three is give the baker's
dozen the baker's dozen an expression at
least from the donut world that's how I
learned about it where the donut store
they would sell a dozen donuts that's
usually 12 but the baker's dozen they
would throw in a 13th they won it for
you for free so if you about twelve you
get 13 called the baker's dozen apply
that same mindset mentality into
everything that you're doing not just
the business but every relationship that
you invest in you want them walking away
feeling like they got insane value that
you are giving more than what they pay
for that they paid for 12 and you gave
them 13 that they paid 4x and you gave
them X plus y plus C always when I go
speak at events I get hired to speak in
that event but I'm always saying hey use
me I'm here for two days three days use
me I want to be used I can do breakfast
meetups I can do lunch meetups I can do
salsa dancing I can I can do an award
ceremony like use me I want to be used I
hate sitting here and and not using my
time effectively I want to be used I
want your conference to be a success how
can I help you and even if I'm the intro
or closing keynote speaker I want to be
you I want to be fully booked up all the
way through if I'm here I want to bring
you massive value where most people come
in and they do their one hour speech
they fly in they fly out I look at the
Toronto workshop that I'm doing where
I'm taking 10 to 15 thought leaders and
helping them learn how to make money
he's being a thought leader I did the
first one I made the next ones in
September and at the dinners in May
people said this is so much insane value
like I would pay three four times this
much I've gotten way more value than I
expected coming in I expected a lot and
you blew me away and that should be your
default mode I hope that I bring you
with these videos way more value than
you ever would expect in a free YouTube
video hopefully that's why you watch
hope that's why I subscribe hopefully
end up telling your friend hope that
provides enough of branding and
economics that you are interested in the
book or any other stuff that I'm doing I
bring you so much value in a free video
and you want to take that mindset to
everything that you're doing it doesn't
mean everything has to be free but
everything that you touch every hour
that you spend with somebody the time
the products the services everything
that you touch should be way more value
for that person than they ever expected
even if they have massive expectations
coming in you always need to blow them
away provide the baker's dozen now I've
got a really special bonus clip for you
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day I want to know what are you
gonna do to provide more value for one
of your customers today leave it down in
the comments below
I absolutely know I will be the greatest
entrepreneur of this era because I'm
gonna win on the two fronts that people
gonna judge by I'll make enough money so
that I'm in the conversation and I will
inspire and help more entrepreneurs than
the rest of the field combined I'm
talking all of them because what Elon
Musk does in his actions to inspire is
incredible it's incredible and Steve
Jobs and then but what I'm doing is
different and I know it the end cuz and
by the way it's cuz I want it more
something I'm better I just want that
that's the part I want I'm it's what
this whole thing is that's why the
document like people only understand
what I'm actually doing that I'm leaving
so much like from a businessman see but
I'm leaving so much money on the table
well money's not to go no you know
what's funny for me money stop being the
goal at $100,000 I couldn't believe I
made a hundred thousand dollars a year I
was like that was it and since then
nothing's been the same doesn't feel the
same not a million not a million doesn't
feel the same 100,000 all right so here
is the reality about money so the reason
that people chase it even though I know
you've heard a thousand times and it is
absolutely true money can't buy
happiness that if you're chasing money
the odds of you ending up with some
level of dissatisfaction is incredibly
high but the reason that people ignore
that and the reason that they keep
chasing it the reason that I myself live
the cliche of money can't buy happiness
is because money actually does have
power now the thing that money lets you
do the thing that gives it that power
the reason that people will chase for
ever and ever and ever is it is the
great facilitator now being the great
facilitator does not mean that it gives
you the thing that you secretly want in
your life so here's the punchline about
happiness the goal of all of this the
goal of this game of life that we're all
playing it is not money
it is not success it is entirely brain
chemistry it's entirely how you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
it's about being deeply fulfilled it's
about being
proud of who you are now those are all
for me synonyms it's the same thing
which I'm just going to shorthand to
fulfillment the thing you're chasing is
fulfillment it's the only thing that
doesn't sway with the wind so happiness
in its typical definition is very
transient so I want to shift people over
to thinking about fulfilment fulfillment
is often born of suffering it's born of
not doing something you want to do it's
born of doing the hard things being
proud of yourself
comes from that being proud of yourself
comes from working your ass off to
acquire a set of skills that by the way
in and of themselves in acquiring it you
found that pleasurable it's something
that you're interested in you've
hopefully crafted developed built a deep
passion around and in acquiring those
skills in service of that thing that you
love and enjoy you're able to serve
other people that's it that's the truth
of happiness that's the truth of the
thing that is going to give you that
sense of fulfillment that's going to
allow you to enjoy your life money is
never ever ever in and of itself going
to do that money buys cool money is able
to give you those temporary dopamine
rushes of going and shopping for
something and getting it and then it's
cool but then that coolness factor wears
off very rapidly the flipside of that
using that money to build something that
you believe in that not only empowers
you but helps empower other people that
will help you develop long lasting
fulfillment so that's the real thing but
if you're doing something that isn't
making you a lot of money but you're
passionate about it you enjoy the day
today and it's allowing you to build
skills that serve you and other people I
promise you if you had to choose between
the two which by the way you don't but
if you had to choose between the two
always in forever every single time
choose fulfillment what's wrong what's
wrong
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be kind of like a little
beacon if you want to know what Will
Smith Tony Robbins Oprah and others have
to say about adding massive value go
check out the video next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there putting
something in the world of value value
value add value to people add some value
create the most value